if we step back to let's say
february of 2020
how how dangerous a disease is covid and
then
the same question for the present day to
a doctor like you who has experience and
all the tools necessary at their
disposal
for an infection there probably is no
other infection that we now understand
is so amenable to risk stratification
how can the same viral infection be
fatal
in an octogenarian and have it be less
than a common cold in a kindergarten
aged child
that the principle that's called wrist
stratification it's actually probably
due to the density of ace2 receptors in
the human body if the virus actually
gains entry into the human body through
the ace2 receptor and to a lesser extent
the tempus 2 receptor it turns out that
we have a lesser density of h2 receptors
in older individuals those who are
smokers and disease but the virus
doesn't the number of receptors doesn't
matter in terms of entry but the number
of receptors that actually exist since
they're destroyed by the entry that the
number the sheer number protect provides
protection
against uh protection against uh
basically a a catastrophe in the lungs
was called the respiratory distress
syndrome we also know that the
proclivity for blood clotting increases
over time there's thousands of
determinants of coagulation and the very
unique thing about this virus is that
the mode of death is micro blood clots
that occur throughout the body the lungs
and there are fatal
thromboembolic consequences almost every
autopsy i'm aware of fred has shown the
lungs are filled with blood clots at the
time of death so it's the idea that risk
stratification is so huge and so it can
be very deadly in an octogenarian and is
completely benign in a school-aged
children that risk stratification must
be applied with every single inference
we make in the pandemic
yeah that's fascinating um and it is
obviously at odds with a
public health response that seems to be
one size fits all almost to a cartoonish
degree the idea
that vaccines are inherently the right
response
that
the fact that these vaccines are
incredibly
novel at a technological level they are
marvel but
they are novel and the idea that we
should be interested in
immediately vaccinating the entire world
if we can reach them with these novel
technologies effectively
uh dragging the entire human species
into a
what i would call a uh
an irresponsibly uncontrolled experiment
seems preposterous i mean as you point
out
very
young healthy children are effectively
at zero risk from covet is that a fair
statement
it's a fair statement we've looked at
obviously we're at now in the last two
meetings with the fda on the p the
pediatric and adolescent vaccination
september and october of 2021 there's a
general recognition through may that 40
of children have already had covet 19.
that's through may that's before the
delta outbreak the delta outbreak was
huge in the united states you know it
was two-thirds of the peak of our
pre-vaccination peak and we know there
it actually seemed to prey upon the
young and so my estimate would be a i i
would put a number on it 80 percent of
children now that are in the discussion
for vaccination have already had covet
and now the cdc in the last week has
acknowledged uh that they don't have a
single case of someone who has recovered
from covet getting it a second time and
passing to anyone so it's basically over
with we have now the cdc estimates are
generally for the united states 148
million americans through may are
immune that they actually have had
coveted 19 and they have natural
immunity that's now supported by over
120 studies that's been by the way
accumulated on the brownstone institute
website 120 studies supporting natural
immunity
it's a one and done phenomenon the only
confusion that exists out there is a
second positive test that can happen as
a false positive test and some early
confusion on the original cdc essay not
being able to distinguish between flu
and covet 19 but in terms of scientific
reality one only gets covet 19 infection
once the immunity is robust complete and
durable just like sars kovi one they're
90 similar as the virus that natural
immunity is going to carry us and you're
right the public health response has not
been along the lines of risk
stratification as it is with other
vaccines you know we don't carpet bomb
the entire population for the
meningococcal vaccine it's kids who go
to college and live in dormitories get
the meningococcal vaccine americans
don't have a problem with that because
it's safe and effective and it's
appropriately risk stratified
the same thing with the pneumococcal
vaccine we give the pneumococcal vaccine
to seniors because they're at risk for
pneumococcal pneumonia we don't give it
to children because they're not at risk
the same risk stratification principles
for other vaccines should have always
been applied to the cova 19 vaccines
yes it looks to me and of course i'm a
scientist not a medical doctor but it
looks to me like every normal
medical standard and uh convention has
been thrown out that effectively the
standard of care is not based on the
kind of scientific deliberation that you
would imagine would have to be
at the the foundation
that the right to informed consent is
nowhere in evidence
and that we are effectively
uh
well if this was a scientific question
rather than a medical question
i would say something has started with
the conclusion and worked backwards
which is
the greatest scientific sin that there
is
um and in this case
it has the added horror of putting human
health and well-being
in jeopardy
and
i'm not sure the problem is that that
what i've just said
seems to me quite uncontroversial
actually just the simple facts of what
we are doing the idea that anybody would
think to vaccinate children who are safe
from this disease
with a vaccine even if we did not have
any evidence of harm which is not the
case
with these vaccines the idea that
anybody would vaccinate people who are
at no risk who have a long life ahead of
them many of whom have already had a
disease that provides robust immunity
the idea that we would expose them to
any risk at all from vaccines that are
so new
is preposterous and yet
when i look at the explanation for why
we're doing that
it's in
vague almost childish terms right the
idea is somehow that vaccines are good
and that you are you know you are doing
something for your child
by uh by inoculating them
without any
anything that looks like an adult risk
benefit analysis
so
what has happened such that the
interface between the public and
medicine
is now looks like
more like pr
and customer service than it does like
science and medicine
one of the most flagrant examples of
what you just mentioned was recently
cnn medical correspondent sanjay gupta
appeared on sesame street
and was with another cnn correspondent
effectively seducing children into
taking the covet 19 vaccine without
presenting a fair balance between the
potential benefits and risks of the
medical product you know we have laws in
place we have pharmaceutical ever
that americans get a fair balance of
benefits and risks and you're right
that's been abrogated in this case
there's been a giant abrogation of
medical ethics of pharmaceutical
pharmacal vigilance and and regulatory
principles
and it's extraordinarily dangerous i i
think historians will write about this
for years to come how did how did
america go off the rails i recently had
dinner with scott atlas we spoke at a
symposium together and scott used that
term over and over again he said things
are off the rails we're not following
any of the general rules
well what could have been different that
was your question brett what could have
been different what could have been and
should have been different is teams of
doctors
we should have had teams of qualified
doctors working along four principles
and i presented this to america when i
testified in the u.s senate in november
of 2020. i said listen we should have
had a team that was totally focused on
reducing spread of the illness great a
separate team focused on early treatment
yet another team focused on in-hospital
treatment and then a final team focused
on vaccination those teams should have
been gathered they could have met
virtually and they should have given at
least weekly or monthly reports with
evidence reviews and scientific updates
you know we're not having any formal
evidence reviews and scientific updates
in these in the three impo four
important areas called the four pillars
of pandemic response i ultimately
published that well i can tell you if we
had the right committee structure in
place and and for vaccines we obviously
should have had a data safety monitoring
board a critical event committee and
human ethics board
[Music]
you